[Müzik]
Müsaadenizle Beyler Biraz da ben
konuşacağım belki sözlerin mühim belki
de
Yalan dolu kimse sevmez nasihat almak
Ben de istesen de yok yorgunum Yaralıyım
ortama yabancıyım
yüzyıldan kaldım direnmekte mahirim
içimdeki korkularla nükleer bir cahilim
bir İskender değilim ama belki biraz
şairim en sağlam direniş kalbi temiz
tutmak şahidim aşk varsa şu alemde başka
şey yok Hacet tam tersi bir anlamda
kullanılırsa şayet kalemi kır ipimi çek
her ölü bir yere gömülecek yenilsek de
yanılsak da pes etsek de bilinecek hadi
götür beni
uzaklarıma geriz kalmadan
[Müzik]
boşa geçen
yıllık beni uzaklarına keriz kalmadı
geçiş boşa geçen yıllarımızı bana
sormadan
onlar hep vardılar kurulumlar koydular
bir vicdanımız var diye bizi aptal
sandılar yanıma gelen kapımı çalan elimi
tutan kimse yok yine de başımı eğmeden
yürüyorum ki zevki çok senle gel eski
kahramanların şimdi yaptığını yapıp
dünyayı kurtaralım
süper güçse lazım olan ziyadesiyle var
kanımızda radyasyon
çernobilden Yadigar
Hadi götür beni uzaklarına geri iz
kalmadan
[Müzik]
geri getir boşa geçen yıllarımızı bana
sormadan
Hadi götür beni
uzaklarına geliriz kalmadan
geri getir boşa geçen yıllarımızı bana
sormadan
içimi
ısıtan Saçım okşayan Rüzgar Çoluk
çocuğumun rızkını çıkardığım şu gitar
hepsi şahit aklımı gelip gidişine
vuramadık be kardeşim bir topum gelişine
tarantina filmindeyiz sanki kanlı
sahneler Ahmet Ümit romanlarındaki gibi
tekinsiz bir yer
ve başlasın
[Müzik]
Hadi götür beni
uzaklarıma geri iz kalmadan
geri getir boşa geçen yıllarımızı bana
sormadan
beni
uzaklarıma geri iz kalmadan
geri getir boşa geçen yıllarımızı bana
sormadan
uçmakla oluyorsa bu işler ne ara ama
nedense içinde kuşkular var hala yine de
bakınız sesimi duyana Sudaki dumana bin
selam Tam şu an karanlıktan iz kalmadan
[Müzik]
çok teşekkür ediyoruz değerli arkadaşlar
nispeten yeni şarkılarından biri olan iz
kalmadan da başladık
şimdi hayatta yaptığım ilk besteyle
devam edeceğiz
büyük Türk şairi Ataol behramoğlu'nun
bir şiirini bestelemiştim 17-18 yaşında
olmanın çılgın jüri ile Kendisi de izin
vermişti sonra başka sanatçı
arkadaşlarımız tarafından da
seslendirildi onlar da güzel söylediler
biliyor olabilirsiniz beraber söylersek
ama ne güzel olur
[Müzik]
Bu Aşk Burada Biter ve ben çekip giderim
yüreğimde bir çocuk Cebimde bir revolver
Bu Aşk Burada Biter İyi günler sevgilim
ve ben çekip giderim bir nehir atıp
gider Bu Aşk Burada Biter ve ben çekip
giderim yüreğimde bir çocuk cebimde oy
ver o Aşk Burada Biter İyi günler
sevgilim ve ben çekip giderim bir nehir
atıp gider
bir hatıradır şimdi dalgın uyuyan şehir
solarken
albümlerde
çocuklar ve askerler
yüzünde bir kır çiçeği gibi
ce söner
uyku ve
unutkanlık
küçükçe derinleşir
Bu Aşk Burada Biter ve ben çekip giderim
yüreğimde bir çocuk Cebimde bir revolver
Bu Aşk Burada Biter İyi günler sevgilim
ve ben çekimlerim bir nehir Akıp Gider
yan yana uzanacak ve
ıslaktı Çimenler ne kadar güzeldin
sen
ve nasıl eşsiz bir yazdı
bunu
anlattılar hep yani içen bir
aşkı geçerken bu dünyada
şairler Şimdi size
[Müzik]
bu kadar mı bilenler
İyi günler sevgilim ve ben çekip giderim
bir nehir Akın gider Bu Aşk Burada ve
ben çekip giderim yüreğimli bir çocuk
senin de bir revolver Bu Aşk Burada
Biter İyi günler sevgilim Ben çekin
giderim bilmeyi bırakıp gider ve ben
çekip giderim
gider ve ben çekip giderim bir ne
[Müzik]
hir akıp giden
oğluna da buradan selam olsun bir alkış
Lütfen Allah başımızdan eksik etmesin
kendisini
Şimdi de efendim hayatta sözü ve müziği
bana ait olarak yaptığım ilk şarkıyla
huzurlarınızdayım
Cep telefonlarından
ve internetten önce bestelenmiş bir
şarkı ama bugün hala konserlerde
söylenebiliyor hatırlayan gençler
olacaktır Sana Dair
Evet telefonları yatmanın tam zamanı
yaşam kadar gerçek
yaşamak gibi sahte Bravo
öyle çok şey var ki yaralayan insanı
bir yürek Çarpın
tısı
[Müzik]
yanlış aşklar yaşadık yanlış köprülerde
yanlış gemiler yakıp aldırmadan
iki damla suç aldık zamanın pençesinden
aldırmadan
Bunu senden kaçışım ne de hiç düşüşün
yüreğime
ne bu senden son geçişimde son küsüz
bu ne senden ilk kaçışım ne de hiç
düşüşünü yüreğime
ne bu senden son geçişim ne de son
küsişim kaderime
kemanda Müge Alpay
dişlerini
[Müzik]
mucize gerek bize
gidecek bir başka düş
Bir düş ki korkmamış zamanın karşısında
ve bir çağ gerek bize
bir çabından Özgür
öyle çok şey var ki bak sana da iyi
iyi sonra Kuşlar gitsin
anladık dünyayı
sen yorgun
tortusu kalmış eski bir korkunun Ne oldu
telefonlar
duymadı
demedi kollar götürdü
aşk var mıydı
ne bu senden son geçişim ne de son kişi
sin kaderime
[Müzik]
bu ne senden mi kaçışım ne de hiç düşün
yüreğime
ne bu senden son geçişimde son kişi kim
kaderime
[Müzik]
kaçışım ne
düşün yüreğime
ne bu Serden son geçişimde
[Müzik]
Ay çok güzelsiniz
kaderime
[Müzik]
konseptimiz
şarkıların da X ve bilinmeyen tarafları
vardır Ben X ve bilinmeyen tarafı olan
bir şarkıdan bahsedeceğim Şimdi size
Müslüm Gürses'in Affet şarkısı
Bu şarkını Bu şarkıyı ben yazdım
işte şarkıları x taraflarından biri bu
Müslüm Gürses için yazdım Müslüm Gürses
ama o kadar güzel söyledi ki
başka kimse o kadar güzel söyleyemedi
özür dilemem gereken bir kadın vardı
çünkü ona yeter Sen yazmıştım
boşanıyordum O sırada hem de ilk defa
boşanıyordum o yüzden heyecanlıydım
sonrakiler de alıştım çünkü
Ama bu ilk olduğu için tabii ki o
heyecanlı yazıldı şarkı
özeldi Müslüm Gürses de sağ olsun Çok
güzel söylediler Ahmetli Biz de şimdi
onu yad edelim mi burada
Ama beraber söyleyeceğiz yer yer Kaçmak
yok telefonları da bekliyorum Evet
[Müzik]
Eğer seni kırdıysam
darıl bana Ama bir gün beni ararsan
bak ruhuna
Bir de gecem tutarsa güneşi çevir bana
sevgili
bağışla biraz zor olsa da
affet beni akşamüstü
gölgen uzarken
öğleden sonra Fes ne zaman
istersen
affet beni gece vakti
Ay Doğmuş süzülürken sabaha kalmadan
Affet tam ayrıldık derken
Çünkü sen
çölüme yağmur oldun
sen
geceme gündüz oldu
[Müzik]
acıma yorgan oldun
Sen şu canıma yoldaş oldun
[Müzik]
affet beni akşamüst
gölgem uzarken
Öğleden sonra Affet Ne zaman
istersen
affet beni gece vakti Ay Doğmuş
süzülürken
sabaha kalmadan Affet tam ayrıldık
derken
Çünkü sen
çölüme yağmur oldun geceme gündüz sen
geceme gündüz oldun Bravo
Sen
canıma yoldaş oldun
kaşıma yorgan oldum
Çünkü sen
çölüme yağmur oldun
sen geceme gündüz oldun
Sen şu canıma yoldaş oldun
sen
kaşıma yorgan
[Müzik]
oldum bir Alkışla Müslüm Gürses için
duy bizi Müslüm Baba duy
Evet şimdi gene coşkuyla beraber
söyleyeceğimiz bir şarkıyla Biz ayrılan
sürenin sonuna doğru yavaştan gelelim
diyorum bizden öncekiler olduğu gibi
bizden Sonrasında da kim bilir ne
aydınlatıcı kafa açıcı
Ufuk geliştirici şeyler var
burada size biraz güzel hoşça bir Seda
bırakabildiysek ne mutlu bize
[Alkış]
Evet telefonlar
tam Bu şarkı için ben
Haydi bakalım
Sen yağmuru çok seven küçücük şey
ben kendine geç kalan bir kadın
beni sevmesen de Yok Desende Güneş doğ
Ama kendimi sevmezdim şimdiki kadar
beni seçmes
ende sende Ateş Yanar diline
Ama gülmeyi bilmezdim şimdi ki kadar
birden geldin aklıma
verdim ışıkları
hayretin kalbime bazen
Mutluluktan
birden geldin aklıma
yakıverdin ışıkları
Hayret ettim kalbime bazen Mutluluktan
[Müzik]
Sen kalbime denk gelen küçücük şey
Ben kendini Aşk sanan bir adam
beni sevmesen de Yok Desende Güneş
doğardı
[Müzik]
yine Ama kendimi sevmezdim şimdiki Kader
seçmesen de Yok Desende Ateş yanardı
yine
Ama gülmeyi Bilmezdim şimdiki Kader
birden geldin aklıma
verdin ışıkları
Hayret ettim kalbime bazen Mutluluktan
bir ben geldin aklıma
yakıverdin ışıkları
Hayret ettim kalbime bazen
Mutluluktan kimler biliyor bakalım
birden geldin
[Müzik]
aklıma harikasınız
da çıkabilir sesini sanki
[Müzik]
harika
birden geldin aklıma
yakıverdim ışıkları
Hayret ettim kalbime bazen Mutluluktan
birden geldin aklıma
Yıllarım
Hayret ettim kalbime bazen Mutluluktan
[Müzik]
bizi buraya davet eden Ankara Tetik
organizasyonuna
bu dolu dolu etkinlikten yararlanmak
için burayı dolduran Siz aydınlık
insanlara
ve buraya ev sahipliği yapan bu
etkinliğe Bu kültür yuvasına çok
teşekkür ediyoruz
beğendiniz Tuna Kiremitçi
kemandaki arkadaşımla
bir başka yerde bir başka güzellikte
tekrar beraber olmak üzere hep böyle
güzel kalın hep böyle aydınlık kalın
Yüzünüzdeki Işık Hiç Gitmesin
ahiret ettim kalbime bazen
[Müzik]
mutluluk
Tan
Çok teşekkür ederim
Sağ ol
[Müzik]